欢迎来到科技修道院，我是北明乘海生。
大家好，我是东东腔。
今天咱们聊的话题是眼镜，叫智能眼镜，AR眼镜都行啊。
我们俩其实用的都不是很多，但是今天咱们又请来老朋友徐然老师。
他是这个眼镜的自身用户，他原来不戴眼镜，为了体验AR眼镜。
专门禁视了。
你把这眼镜弄坏了。
副厨太太，大家好，大家好，我是北京交通广播FM1039的徐然。
很开心又来串台了。
太好了。
还有一位呢，是张总您自个介绍一下，他是跟眼镜相关的一个从业者。
大家好，我是北京都市科技公司的创始人张言。
我们主要是做端测计算的。
太高官了。
什么叫端测计算？您给讲。
就是你看那小片的时候，把那个二维的，接着张总他们那个计算的设备，就变成三维的了。
等等，不动，最近正查这个呢，我就说，一个，我觉得你说的肯定不严谨。
能把一个二维的二地的偏远变成一个三地的效果，是这样吗？
是的，是的，就是这个我先解释，跟各位老师解释一下这个端测计算啊。
这个端测计算，它的来源就是我的计算不需要网络。
我们现在大部分的计算其实都需要网络，我需要跑到云端，这样它导致的问题其实有很多的，
包括收费问题，业务问题，严实问题，网络实元隐私问题。
那我们公司其实主要的能力就是要解决这些数据的处理问题，
我们就要把所有的处理进可能玻璃云。
让它在一个小盒子上。
或者什么地方把这个计算给完成了。
那么我们其中有一个品。
就是各位老师说的。
就是说二地转三地转。
因为它对体验和延时要求很高是吧？
我刷手机我想看一个三地斗的斗。
因为我不可能说刷半天。
这流还没下滥是吧？
那它就需要很及时的反馈。
那我们就需要一个很端侧的一套计算系统。
来完成这个转换
那为什么要做这个事呢？
因为现在眼镜呢？
它作为一个显示器是吧？
我们同样来说
它就是个比电视更高级一些的显示器。
一个面板吧小小鱼。
更高级一些的显示器。
那么这个显示器
因为咱们都是做媒体的嘛？
你要做显示器
你最大的问题就是我内容从哪儿来。
对没有这个三地内容。
眼镜发挥不出优势来。
对 那我们就去看二地的不行吗？
二地的你拿手机看了。
那就纯面上一头戴显示器了。
对 是吧？
没必要
对 如果我们看二地的就会有个问题。
就是我们为什么要用眼镜了。
是吧？
因为你眼镜
既然你都把一个屏幕挂到鼻子上了。
你可能对这个屏幕是要有诉求的。
那这个屏幕一定是能给你提供一个更。
庆祝式的那种感受的。
那如果你看到的内容还是传统的内容。
它就违背了咱费这么大劲。
把这个屏幕往鼻子上放在这个初衷了。
是吧？
那我们就尽可能的说。
在现有这种芯片和计算能力的基础上。
尽可能把节目给它丰富起来。
然后有更多的节目加载到显示器里头去。
那个显示器就能发挥它应有的一些作用。
感觉是为了内容做了个硬件。
这还挺厉害的
这个真能做到
因为我都没见过这技术。
把任何传统的2D的视频节目。
比如猫和老鼠
然后我们用本地的设备。
就能把它转成双眼观看的3D效果。
我也觉得对
很震撼
其实今天
那个
因为我今天我不知道这个。
这个需要拿过来给各位老师说。
咱是音品节目
您也展示不了
对
能咱们先聊
所以当时如果我知道说。
今天要展示一下
其实我应该拿不了。
因为这个在我印象中。
比如说一个传统的2D电影。
比如当年太胆尼克号。
他要做一个3D版。
这还是一个兴师动众的大工程。
是吧？
他才能做出一个来呢？
我们目前这个技术。
其实在整个业界算是非常先进的。
因为谷歌
要到今年的8到10月份。
才能Release这么一个世界模型的小模型。
到就今年底
他可能才发布这么个模型。
然后国内的华为
目前还没有拿出一个太太座。
华为老大哥也在做。
但是他也没有拿出一个真正能放在桌面上。
就能给人用的了
我们这个产品现在已经在卖了。
只是
只是因为眼镜端现在生产有一些问题。
我们那就是眼镜的库存不够。
然后我们的样机
昨天被一个另外一个老大哥。
拿去给国外的有人要去做展示。
然后彭总今天
昨天我不知道他说。
他特别晚过说
说你眼镜那么拿来。
一会我说
我说你稍微早料
拿过来就马上咱们用手机。
就可以去实现呈现了是吧？
那我很想问你们这眼镜是什么形态。
是我们三阿带的这种乍一看。
它就是一普通眼镜的形态。
对
这个眼镜对于我们来说。
它其实就是个显示器了。
所以目前上
它就长这样
对
它得是那种把眼睛蒙上的那种。
它应该是个挺大的东西吧？
我感觉
不用很大
其实就比我这大
比起说那个眼镜稍微重一点。
重一点
稍微大一点
但它外形基本上也就是我这样的外形。
就咱们市面上哪些眼镜能用。
对
我目前我选的是国外的一个品。
然后国内的像雷鸟雷鸟那个眼镜。
我觉得也是可以的。
雷鸟也可以
对
X-Rail那个软件。
那个也是可以的
但是我为什么选国外那个品呢？
因为它那个市场角。
做的会更大一些
然后再有一个呢？
它那个国外的眼镜比较皮士。
我我测试了国内的一些眼镜。
主要的问题就是
因为我这个经常给客人去用啊？
他用时间长的腿都是。
国内很多眼镜的腿。
因为它都是塑料腿嘛？
它会松是不是
对
它松或者就干脆就舌了。
然后我们国外那个我拿了一个品牌。
就到现在还是很皮士的。
因为它那个是个金属腿。
然后呢？
它那个市场角现在也是不错的。
就是它市场角是问题。
看进去那个木的大小。
看上去有点像
宽一木
看进去就是一个特别宽的宽一木。
那我还想请问
就关于外形的问题。
就是硬件的问题
您刚才说是找了国外的相当于一个工厂。
是吗？
还是他们国外的一个品牌。
一个品牌
现有的眼镜
现有的品牌
就是你这个算法
应该是直接接到现有的眼镜上就行。
就行
对
就相当于您是做了一套软件体系。
我能这么理解吧？
做了
对
它的核心是软件
但是呢？
它的复杂度就在于说。
我们必须这个软件和一套芯片。
配合起来才行
理解
那肯定
那如果拿国外的现成的这个品牌来讲。
它这个眼镜的本体。
就是这个硬件本体。
不需要做调整吗？
在调整上
我们就是我们那个软件。
可能需要给眼睛稍微适配一下。
适配啥
就是它不同的眼镜。
可能它那个分辨率不太一样。
市场角可能不太一样。
然后这个两边的这个。
比如说因为是3D的嘛？
它就左右眼的这个图。
它可能结构不太一样。
我有点理解
我们去适配一下
张老师的意思了
因为我过去试过X-Rail的几个眼镜。
X-Rail其实在咱们国内的。
我们科技媒体的语境当中。
管这种眼镜叫AR眼镜。
它是一种混合现实的这样的一种。
叫X-R
对
AR和VR中间的一个。
X-R
对吧？
就是它是这样的
就是你看我们这个眼镜。
它是单片的
它就是薄薄的这种状态。
但它那个眼镜不是。
它那个眼镜是在拿下来之后。
它在眼镜片上会有一个小屏幕。
对对对
有个屏幕
对它会有一个屏幕。
多了一层呗
多了一个屏幕
所以你如果把那种眼镜摘下来。
它不是一个薄片
它是个什么呢？
它是一个歇形
能理解吗？
它就不是像我们这种薄薄的这种镜片。
对你这就是一普通的眼镜。
对
我说嘛？
就跟咱们稍微有区别。
就它那个里边做了一个歇形。
它主要就是为了投出来那个。
三地的场景
沉浸式的场景
它是这样的
所以这个硬件成本其实并不便宜。
就像说到最早是不是就是苹果出的那个东西。
就是这样
苹果不是
苹果那是投下
那是个VR
对
那还不太一样
它是全包裹的
对
现在它那个
咱们就把它当一个显示器。
它有几种实现方式。
我大概跟各位老师这个会报一下。
您可以说说我们都想听。
它VR
我们先从VR上说。
VR它就是全包裹的。
你比如说代表做
就是像国内的Pico。
然后国外的像
Viren Pro。
就苹果的
当然Mata也有。
Mata的那个
它其实根本的逻辑特别简单。
它就是
你这个屏幕在正前方。
然后它中间通过一组放大镜。
然后这个放大镜和这个屏幕。
有取了个名字叫Pancake。
它其实也没那么厚。
大概这么厚吧？
然后它相当于我眼睛前头有两个特别大的屏幕。
然后通过个放大镜。
把这个屏幕给放大了。
然后我包裹在脑袋上。
然后好处就是它的成绩感非常强。
它的随动感也非常强。
它的整个计算系统也在眼镜上。
当然它也可能把计算系统给分出来。
但是它那个眼镜的成像效果。
因为它全包围的
所以它那个眼镜的成像效果就非常好。
但是它有一个致命的缺点。
因为你像在前头放了两个显示器。
就是自然的视线就完全被遮挡了。
对 但是你只能看里边的东西。
撞墙
对 不叫眼镜
其实对吧？
它就是你带了块屏幕。
像是头盖显示器
对 没错
但是你说我想看外面怎么办。
它又有一个技术叫C-SOO。
然后它就相当于在眼镜的。
正中间放了一颗摄像头。
它就是
它拍的东西给你撥出来。
你看飞镜了吧？
它拍的东西撥出来。
对 然后它就拍了。
但是我看到的是眼前清净的现场直播。
对 拍的是你
但是就有一个问题。
它为什么叫C-SOO呢？
是因为这个相机从采集到你眼睛。
它不是有延时吗？
对
你这个延时如果跟你的感觉不是很同步。
你就晕彩了
嗯
你就要速度很快
对
所以解决C-SOO的问题非常困难。
这第一个
第二个
因为你眼睛是个立体的。
你从C-SOO看到的有可能是一个摄像机拍到。
它就不是立体的
你走路的时候就有点。
摔跤
这就是我为什么要配眼镜的原因。
因为我爱摔跤
两个眼睛看到的东西不一样。
一会我再展开讲
您先给大家讲完科普玩一下。
这个科普不敢
因为我毕竟不是眼镜从业者。
所以我说起来有时候就。
就可能直一下
对
挺好的
你说太专业了
我们听不懂
谁也找来了竞作广告。
哈哈哈哈
所以你像这个C-SOO。
这个C-SOO带来的问题就是说。
哎
我如果放异科上级。
没有立体感
这个人在走路的时候。
他就很难受
那我要解决的问题。
我觉得他放这两颗。
产生这种三地感
让人跟看到外面的一样。
你放了两颗了之后。
你这两颗的位置
你放哪
然后他产生的三地和人。
这间三地是不是完全能匹配上。
等等相关的问题又出来一对。
所以大家就是
其实最后做这个VR眼镜。
大家都是为了一袍醋。
包了个饺子真的
就是带持续的包饺子。
对
就是
然后包到最后
其实还有一个很大的问题就是。
因为它是个全包裹。
所以你这个眼睛散热。
是一个很大的问题。
嗯
而且它挺重的
对
那个一定不会很舒服的。
VR Pro用完了。
我记得特清的
我用了半小时
就是整个这块
你摘完了以后
全是一样
就是特别明显这一道。
就是你额头站满
勒出一样的
对
那个特别沉
挺沉的反正
一瓶矿泉水吧？
基本上就是
那一直带着它
还影响我带假发
真是
我磨了一下
磨了一下
对
就这是VR眼镜
这是老大帽子
对
才知道
这怎么还才知道
没关系
反正这VR眼镜
您刚刚说特对
我觉得赵老师好专业。
他都太谦虚
因为您说的
那个Saysrew的那个问题。
它是这样的
就我们人脑
其实是一个非常精密的计算体系。
它从
就是它看摄像头拍到的东西。
和你人实际的感知。
其实可能现在的技术。
已经能把实验做到非常低了。
苹果就做的很低
十几毫秒
对吧？
但是我们人
它就有一个很先天的体系。
如果它判断
你身体看到的东西。
跟感觉的这两套体系。
它不一样的时候
它就会让你恶心
因为它觉得
它千百年的DNA眼镜历史。
告诉它
你现在中毒了
你得通过头晕恶心。
把你吃的有毒的东西给吐出来。
这题是你不对劲
对
就是这事不对
你就赶紧从这个状态里出来。
是不是运车的就这么回事。
对 就是这个意思。
因为我们大脑里面有一个东西。
它叫内耳前庭
内耳前庭
根据每个人的个体。
它是敏感程度不一样的。
有的人为什么特别容易运车。
就是它的内耳前庭特别敏感。
这就属于眼镜测试圣体。
因为但凡
它看到的东西
跟身体感知到的东西实验场。
它就特别容易晕
恶心
但如果有的人不敏感。
他不爱运车
那这种眼镜
他就用着会比较舒服。
因为即使你实验长一点。
也OK
我就是那内耳前庭。
格外敏感的人
你肯定没有我妈敏感。
我妈运车运到什么时候。
这还攀地上了
火车都做不了
有这种人
从来没有做过
是吧？
虽必要
所以我不做眼镜
所以就得干这行
我就没法做眼镜
因为戴不了
就我根本戴不了
我自己一戴就晕
戴不了是
就一戴就晕
一戴就晕
做多好都晕
我就戴一个平光镜。
我都晕
你这是我妈那时候。
从大星到回龙冠
是骑子型车
大星到回龙
哎呦
二子天
做不了车
公交车地铁都不行。
都不行
火车都不行
公交车地铁
那车就什么的
更没戏了
是吧？
对
所以从来不出警
那这些做眼镜的公司快晚。
你母亲
太老人家
这真的这绝对需要贡献。
百万年薪
绝对的
有气法
需要贡献
这这是唯一一个
靠晕赚钱的人
哈哈哈哈
就这上天赐予的礼物。
真的
刘鹏老师
原来咱们可能不知道。
就是这个功能这么值钱。
他戴着他娃娃兔
你这
我这眼睛太熟
太熟了
我也是
我一戴
我也晕得太熟了
所以眼镜就没法做嘛？
就我们做眼镜
做得挺早的
我们原来在11年。
我在英特尔的时候。
我们那时候就跟谷歌。
当时做那个
谷歌格拉斯
谷歌格拉斯第一代的。
就是我们给谷歌
提供的一个
一个一个计算系统。
哦
高兴啊？
我当年
很早就做了
谷歌格拉斯第一代出来的时候。
你还买过
我买过一个
我买了一个
我买了一个送朋友。
哎呦
就是我当时觉得
那是又人类科技的。
那个大成
对
我说太好了这东西。
我当时正好有一朋友帮我一忙。
我原来一是有
我说我送你一东西吧？
我找人
还托人在美国
给我带了一个回来。
那是咱这边没有啊？
他得用原生的Google啊？
对对对
然后呢？
就就买了一个
我印象中一万左右吧？
一万多
我给了我一朋友送他了。
但是说实话
我后来想想挺傻的。
那东西估计
他也用不上什么？
因为当时的那些功能也很。
也很
太超前了
然后计算系统也不行。
主要没生态
没有生态
对
你不知道用它干啥。
是主要是不知道用。
我其实现在我也不知道。
这些眼镜能干啥
其实现在我觉得也还是生态问题。
你看苹果那个东西。
他他为什么生产量小了很多。
就是因为
张总说他缺少那个3D内容。
你带那个玩
首先不能上街
对吧？
弄成一个东西
你只能在屋里看片玩游戏。
可是三维的片也好。
游戏也好
太少了
是是
刚才说
就是费劲巴拉的做一C15。
对吧？
做C15我的理解就是。
你能带着这眼镜可以行动了。
行走
移动了
对
实际上这有可能就是个委需求。
就是他那个玩意儿。
不是说你让我能看到了。
我就能带着他
四处走动
他怎么着也不适合四处走动。
我看到的用那个苹果的。
那个VisionPro的。
我看到的大多数人。
还是带着他玩游戏。
对
玩游戏
刚需
或者是什么长途飞行。
途中我带着他看个片。
我觉得你也够累的。
还不如拿手机看着。
但是玩游戏我能猜测。
那个沉浸感
恐怕是挺好的
是是是
尤其是我看他们有些人玩那些。
模拟飞行类的游戏。
是吧？
对
用那个
雪山滑雪
但是你也不能一边模拟飞行。
这一边出门
在街上走啊？
对啊？
那叫什么？
所以这个C-Sprung。
他我难以理解他
就你玩游戏
都是骑士上个厕所。
能做到这点就可以了。
但是他有线的
可能
还得有线连着
你瞧瞧啊？
对啊？
他有线
其实我们是觉得
就是这两年
我看很多AI硬件。
就是从我做AI媒体的。
这个角度上来讲
有好多功能都属于。
哎 这播客应该能说吧？
能说
因为一会儿有啥不能说的。
不能说他就给剪了。
哦 对对对
特别脱裤
我们一般都这么？
我们一般都这么骗嘉宾说。
没啥用
对对对
其实关键就是留这些。
哎嘛？
再早点来一遍
来来来 您说
就刚刚我们说的那个。
当我不是说C-srew是。
因为它完成这个效果的过程当中。
可能会有很多技术溢出。
但是就是我们现在处于。
这个过渡阶段
就是让人挺难受的。
比如说最近会有一些。
一句话让AI帮你干事的。
这种体验吧？
其实有的时候你会发现。
这就跟新能源汽车里的。
物理按键被取消一样。
有的时候你会发现。
比如说现在已经倒闭这我敢说。
就已经倒闭了的那个。
极月汽车百度起下的。
那个车真的从产品的。
从产品成熟度来讲。
特别好
什么叫好呢？
就是它里边一个物理按键都没有。
挂挡都需要用屏幕去点触。
挂挡你想我们过去开车。
就是要么波崗
要么怀挡
是吧？
就是它是有一个物理的。
按钮的
但那个车就是全部都是虚拟的。
你从产品的维度
它能干成这件事确实特别厉害。
但我就开个空调
我就关一个风
我就调一下
我音量大小
我一下我就能解决。
我现在得进菜单
我得找一找翻一翻。
我就觉得这种功能其实。
为啥呀？
咱这有点跑蹄
但是我也差去嘴
我觉得不太跑蹄
我觉得取消所有物理按键。
是一个非常奇怪的指念。
有的时候那个触感。
以及它给我的实实在在的反馈。
是非常重要的
本人有错误的产品决策。
取消物理按键就意味着你得用眼睛。
用眼睛
这个眼睛在车上是非常宝贵的资源。
是的
所以它倒闭了吗？
其实它做这个
从我们一个技术或者说产品。
我们关心的就是技术产品品味。
我们这几件品味
就是说使用的感受。
这几者之间的关系。
只是因为它的产品和技术。
并没有做到点上
或者说没有
它的完成度并不高。
我给你举个例子
你比如说这个车
如果你把所有物理按键。
都取消在这个情况下。
你就不能再让客户去选了。
你大概率就是自动驾驶了。
就跟那Cyber Truck似的。
就是你不是因为取消物理按键。
而取消的物理按键。
你是因为它真的自己能跑。
这些东西都没用了。
有道理
那你如果你说我做自动驾驶。
我做好了取消
没有问题
是吧？
但是你说我有一个中间态。
我既又
我这边既没做好
那边我还要保持
又取消了
那它有一个中间态。
就会让人
非常难受
对
无法理解
所以现在其实
我觉得
反正就随便说说
没什么？
你都解了
就留点
你想摆渡
因为他们很早就开始做自动驾驶。
我也有很多朋友在里头。
帮着摆渡一起做自动驾驶。
他们原来的这个心态。
还是非常激进的
他们认为说L4
很快就能来
很快就能落地
但是
因为他们说这件事。
是很有根据的
因为你比如说
对于道路的自动驾驶而言。
只是在规则下的避障。
所以这件事情
从科学的原理上来说。
它不会比机器人
简单非常非常多
它就是在规则
你这个路
我线都画好了
我路都修好了
这就是规则
是吧？
只是在规则下的避障。
就是我只是在规则下。
我停走
就这两种状态
那对于摆渡而言
它觉得容易
这不是很容易
但是它有一个问题。
就说好
它
虽然是它解决规则下的避障。
但是
因为在道路行驶中。
有很多反规则的事情发生。
所以就会让这个体系越来越复杂。
复杂
对
你有些人
他就不遵守交通规则。
所以这个体系就会变得越来越复杂。
越来越复杂
导致了说
最后3%
5%
完成不了
完成不了的之后
就会出事
出事的时候
谁扛等等
这个体系
虽然说它的攻势很简单。
但是因为的一些
concass
倒回来
把整个事都毁了
所以
这也是技术
工程
产品
包括客户体验
目标感之后的一个很大的问题。
就是
我这个产品
如果说
我是不是有一个
一个美好的
一个远达的目标是好的。
那肯定是要好的
但是你还得去
真正的去
去感受一下
它离远达目标到底有多远。
是10年
20年
还一辈子都完成不了。
那如果说
它这个年头太长
那有可能
这个需要的资源过多。
是吧？
地球的资源
是不是能支持你这个。
如果能支持不了
你的体系
可能就存在
崩的一个可能性
对
张老师说的这个
我觉得就是现在
我们聊AI眼镜的一个。
一个抓手
就是我们现在做的这个AI眼镜。
现在这些厂商
有没有考虑远棋目标的问题。
他们现在做这个
是基于自己
商业上的考量
还是真正基于您刚才说的。
一个人类比较宏大的。
美好生活愿景的
这么一个目的去做的。
没错
所以在过渡过程当中。
你就会发现有
千奇滚百怪的产品。
就是有很多
产品的技能数
你就不理解
它为什么要这么点。
就很奇怪
但是我觉得从某种程度上来讲。
倒也不能说
他们这么尝试有问题。
因为现在大厂
更多在尝试AI眼镜。
也只有他们能尝试。
因为他们有资源
对吧？
也有钱
所以他们其实尝试起来的成本是低的。
但我倒是觉得
就是现阶段
对于普通消费者来讲。
如果你特别喜欢这东西。
你可以买
如果说你不是特别极客。
我是觉得他还没有进。
没有到那种
能够进入
寻常百姓家的阶段。
我有一个问题是
刚才说现在眼镜
很多都处在过渡阶段。
我觉得是
我能不能问问
那那个终极形态是什么？
假如咱们能克服所有的技术上的壁垒。
咱现在拥有所有的技术。
和甭管人软件的
还是甭管是软件还是硬件的。
一个理想的完美的AI眼镜。
智能眼镜
它该有哪些功能
该实现什么样的效果。
我连这个都想象不出来。
因为说实话
我心里的那个声音是。
人类需要智能眼镜。
吗？
对
就有这个问题
这个其实从一个技术哲学上说。
技术和哲学有时候可能并不分家。
但是一分和不分
可能就是考验一个公司。
一个老板
是吧？
对产品定义的时候。
你既合优的
你是不是有远大的目标。
是不是有近期的
你像比如说我还是从电动车。
聊一下
电动车其实它只是解决。
我从A点到B点的一个关系。
对吧？
所以马斯克才解决这事的时候。
他就比较简单
他说我车里有啥都不要。
我从A点开到B点。
不就完事了吗？
所以他就不太会在车里头。
去做冰箱这类的问题。
是吧？
他就解决一个距离问题。
那解决的是不是核心问题。
肯定是
但是呢？
你上国内为什么要做这件事。
那就是产品的前几百块了。
是吧？
我在这过程中
你既然要花费时间。
那么在这个时间如何消耗掉的。
你肯定就是体验了。
那我给你拼不过
这个自动驾驶
我给你拼不过什么别的。
那我总得有一个产品形态。
跟你不一样
原来是这样
比冰箱吧？
对
那你做仓吧？
其实眼镜从稍微折血。
或者远达目标上来说。
我们只是希望人能进入到。
一种侵入是体验的这种状态。
然后这个状态
因为咱们人
其实70%的时间。
都是不是睡觉就是在玩。
我们工作的时间其实非常少。
你想想为什么抖音这么伟大。
因为它大量消耗你这个娱乐的时间。
是吧？
你想你睡觉8个小时就靠死就过了。
然后你说你工作10个小时。
但是有小时间可能能有4个小时。
这么算这个事
是吧？
然后人大乎了
想想自己的情况
对
哈哈哈哈
这想
然后你像
算墨鱼吧？
你像咱们都算客户。
这是张总的老板视角。
对对对
老看着敌人
我扭滑视角
我好累啊？
哈哈哈哈
那你那你16个小时都在干什么？
那我我希望说
我我有一个品能
能完美的占据
你这16个小时的时间。
那就是世界最伟大的品。
其实大家都在围着奋斗啊？
那有一种方式呢？
就是说
哎我从一个
物理的
这是咱们人经常去解决的一个问题。
就是我从你的感知入手。
什么就从你的眼睛入手。
我给你前头放一些迷魂的整个视觉系统。
让你感觉是进入了你的这个虚拟世界。
这个这个这个做法肯定没毛病。
因为你有16个小时你都想玩吗？
那我要占据你这个入口。
那不就很大的一个口吗？
这这没毛病吗？
没毛病
然后呢？
从马斯克的角度来说呢？
他说
哎你看
我不一定非要从眼睛进入是吧？
我还可以从你脑子进入。
哎这就另外一个血派。
就说呢？
我绕过你眼睛的视觉系统。
我直接从你的处理器。
我从你的处理器入口入手。
我骗你的
我直接我不让你眼睛去采集了是吧？
我直接把图像植入到你脑子里头去。
反正现在这两派都在。
都都都在持续的在战斗。
过渡阶段嘛？
大家还没分出来到底谁更好呢？
但是后面的阶段
显然要比前头那可能。
稍微更可怕一点是吧？
对他绕开了你的视觉系统。
这个我就更可怕
就是爱你
我的这个图像都可以直接植入到。
你脑子里头去
那是不是能写
那写操作读操作
是不是都行
等等等等
这种问题都
论语问题都出现了。
人跟电池之间的关系是吧？
黑客帝国
这系列的问题可能都出现了。
那现在看上去
可能相对与性的做法。
还是我们把人作为一个整体。
我们不要去侵入他这个系统。
还是外挂
哎呀做一个外挂
但是外挂现在就是。
现在发展确实
像VR就已经发展到这个阶段了。
看Cake已经是现在最先进的视觉系统。
那第二套系统就是AR系统。
AR就是
像徐老师带这个
都算是AR
AR的变种非常多。
因为原来AR其实它并不完全是解决。
好多非娱乐性的需求。
对
它只是一个增强现实。
像谷歌格拉斯原来其实也是增强。
就是我增强你的拍摄。
我增强你的导航
我增强你的文本
所以它就有一个很大的问题是。
它不能看片
就简单的说它不能看片。
可是人类就那么需要看片。
人类只需要
这就是另外一个问题。
就是我们需要探讨一下。
另外一个问题就是什么叫娱乐。
你想像整个广电
广电体系是吧？
整个广电
我们这个娱乐
差不多就是除了声音文字。
声音文字 图片 视频。
我们基本上就没别的了。
对 是吧？
原来就看书
原来我听广播 是吧？
然后或许有广电
我看电视剧
然后现在
现在有什么游戏之类的。
对
然后这四种里头
其实跟人最大的娱乐感受。
目前有证据可查的。
肯定就是视觉了
因为视觉它的及时感很强。
就是娱乐到底刺激的是啥。
是多巴胺 是吧？
对
你的这个多巴胺被眼睛。
这种整个这套系统。
你至于现在的短视频刺激到说。
我都没有办法去接受长视频。
对
它就是这种刺激
我这一刺激
马上多巴胺分泌了。
我就嗨了 是吧？
你让我说
一个小时之后多巴胺才分泌。
我受不了
对
那视觉在整个娱乐体系。
是非常重要的 是吧？
视神经是唯一进入大脑。
体系的一个神经
没错
AR的Augment。
这种增强现实的一个部分。
可能就又不行了
所以这就现在有一个很火的赛道。
叫XR
就是说这人又出来了。
又一对兄弟说了
你看
有没有一种可能性。
我把AR和VR的技术。
我变得一块去
变得一块去
这个眼镜特别适于佩戴。
我又能看视频
我通俗的幻想一下。
它是不是就是一副很轻便的眼镜。
这副眼镜当我日常。
比如说做我日常的工作的时候。
生活的时候
它就会像一个
我小时候看美军的机械战警。
就是它在现实中会增加一些提示。
不管是图文的提示。
还是在现实中给你一些符号。
与你的互动
比如说导航
比如说是给你的AI的提示。
说这是什么？
它是出现在我正常的视野中的。
对吧？
它比如说咱们现在聊天的。
在我第一次见到你。
在你的头上就出现。
屈屈屈染
什么北京交通广播主持人之类的。
然后呢？
但是当我需要沉浸娱乐的时候。
它就会自己
对
就像拉上窗帘一样。
变黑了
我的眼前或者它不变黑。
就在我眼前
比如说两米一处
出现了一个
100多寸的大屏幕。
当然是这种
没错
我的想象就是这种。
你已经定义出来了。
现在XR的本质
就这两句话
您看
您已经把整个XR的这个。
这个产品经验
我怎么那么厉害我。
就是这么干的
但是有一个问题
咱们回到VR那块。
它有两个屏幕
遮在你眼睛前面
你如何
它怎么都遮在你的视线。
是吧？
物理上你就挡在你的前头。
对
你把这两个芯片拆开。
它就没屏幕了
对
你挡上它就挡上了。
这是在XR这个世间的。
最大的办角式
就是我的想办法
把这个屏幕挪走
这人都会这么想
你前头这两块布
我想看我就把布拿走。
然后拿走的方法
两种
一种叫几盒的折射。
就是九点像那个
我放在下头
我放在上面或者下面是吧？
然后我一折
但是你无论放上放下。
这都会厚一些
对
就有点像现在
大家肯定在电视里都见过那种提刺器。
提刺器啥
提刺器在屏幕下面。
割一镜面的那个板。
就打上去
现在眼镜其实就是这个。
没错
这是最传统的方法。
就是要几盒折射
现在卖的好的眼镜。
还是采用这种方法的。
我一会再说为啥
然后另外一种方法。
就是叫光波导
这个波导怎么波导呢？
就说好
我把这个屏幕
我挪到腿上去
因为腿我可以粗点。
对吧？
我挪到这来
我把屏幕挪在这
然后我通过一系列的折射。
这有点牛
这就叫现在最先进的。
这个光波导接触
这个光波导其实时间也很长了。
大概有十几年了吧？
大家都在研究说怎么把。
这个有个小光纤织的。
不是 这事这么复杂吗？
它是有一堆的冷镜。
一堆的小冷镜
对 它得实现很多个方向的调整。
它既然有一堆的冷镜的问题是。
它这个加工难度就会非常高。
包括到今天为止
这个眼镜的加工难度都非常非常的高。
光波导
郑老师 我给科技界提供的思路。
来来来
我觉得把这事想复杂。
你们见过那种可折叠的墨镜片没有。
加片
就它的意思就加一个东西。
加一个屏
就物理的 我把它挡下来。
VR
翻上去
AR
就是大家脑袋这
平时都立着俩片
在脑门上
用的时候把它翻下来就得了。
不是不行吧？
现在有一个公司
他做了个眼镜的配件。
然后你往眼镜上挂。
他就把屏幕
就是他有这种弯性的。
就加这吗？
就加
它往这一换
但是这个弯过来的屏幕。
会有一个很大的问题。
那屏幕太小
它没有办法实现大屏的体验。
对 你要弄大的话。
那个Pancake又会很大。
保浪不下来
是吧？
它只要大了之后供电。
这加片不能太重了。
现在看上去
光波岛是有前途的。
是吧？
光波岛
我这个屏幕在这
我说说折过去
完美
是吧？
它无非就成本问题。
但是技术人
路线是完美的
但现在光波岛最大的问题。
是因为它有多层的折射了之后。
折射到最后放在你眼前。
这个图像和原来的图像。
比它的能量损失太大。
它有衰减
我们有效的能量
大概现在只能做到百分之十几。
那还是有点低
你看就会有一个问题。
就是你最后看电影。
会觉得它发污
亮度不够
你去世外
可能这电影都看不到。
所以解决的方法是什么？
那人们都是在为那盘醋。
在不断的弄饺子
是吧？
好
他说
我有一些特别牛逼的屏幕。
我的亮度上万的这种流明。
我把这个屏幕做亮不就行了吗？
哪怕衰减到百分之十几。
它也够亮
那现在大家就是努力的。
那你做亮了之后
你会知道一个问题是。
烫
它会烫吧？
对吧？
烫耳朵
所以你的散热
你的这些东西又
又上来了
而且这个耗电也应该很高。
对
能耗
但是每一个阶段
其实都会对整个人类。
这个技术的进步
会有一些促进作用。
当然
这技术一出
像光波岛
光波岛现在
它在这个技术的一出是。
比如说我们现在有可能能用。
光刻机去刻眼镜
光刻机刻眼镜
眼镜太奢侈了
你说光刻机刻眼镜有什么用。
但是如果光刻机无法刻眼镜。
光波岛技术就无法普遍。
它俩是同一个命题的两个人。
就是我连眼镜片的。
为什么说要用光刻机去刻眼镜。
因为很多度数高的人。
眼镜特别厚
越高越厚
但是你要用光刻机去刻。
它那个镜片可能就一毫米。
能解决所有度数的问题。
是吧？
你就很舒服了
就是这几个眼镜
不保护得无所谓
因为我刻出来的
是吧？
我是按照这种调文刻出来的。
我就可以无任意的让它放大测小。
你刻出来眼镜
你就能解决很多近视的人的问题。
对
是不是
所以现在有一堆兄弟。
从这个
是吧？
说可能我不做无缘的研究。
我做近视镜去了
就一批兄弟就开始去折腾。
这个近视眼镜去了。
对
因为我觉得在光学整个这个行业。
当中有太多太多的技术细节。
可以挖掘了
前两天我就是在配这个眼镜的时候。
正好挖一个楼
我还问朋友
我说我这200多度。
而且我只有左眼有度数。
右眼没度数
因此这个我才配的眼镜。
走路老摔跤啥的
我就问他们
我说我这度数用上蔡司吗？
因为我不懂
但蔡司咱现在都知道。
它其实最核心的那个技术。
就是一层肚膜
因为我们戴眼镜
其实你受到很多复杂光线的影响。
比如说紫白线什么的。
对吧？
所以那层肚膜就显得很重要。
是非常重要
然后他们就开始跟我说各种经验。
首先第一条就是说。
你这度数根本用不上。
其次我又觉得说
那蔡司挺贵的
就是坐下来得2000多块钱。
我这个300块钱解决了。
然后我就说差这么多。
我就不信咱单扬解决不了这个事。
后来他们还跟我说。
还真就解决不了这个事。
是吗？
接着到目前
蔡司的那个肚膜技术。
还是在全球非常非常领先。
而且没有被攻克的。
为啥呢？
是因为其实咱们这边有特别多的。
造假蔡司肚膜的那个技术。
它不是在
不是做假肚膜
它是用了各种各样的手段。
什么验证码吧？
什么那个身份码吧？
它是在这种软件层面上去给你做造假。
让你以为你买到了一个真的蔡司眼镜。
我当然觉得想
你们有这个本事和能耐。
去做这个造假的系统。
你们为什么不能把蔡司肚膜的这个技术。
给攻克一下
攻克不了
这肚膜其实
那个技术
我跟您说你就知道。
它其实特简单
人类最后的复杂的点。
都是特纯粹的点
它肚膜只是为了让它均匀。
它只解决这个事
包括很多天线
比如说那种太空望远镜的一些天线。
它解决都是均匀
它为啥要均匀
因为你比如说眼睛往它肚膜的时候。
我找不均匀
它是光
对 它就看不见了。
它可能就有一些扭曲。
是吧？
然后对你眼睛
你长期佩戴可能就不行。
但是你找均匀
保厚都一样
那就行了
像蔡司什么的
它这个均匀的
像现在那种
比如说像太空的一些望远镜。
它在肚膜上都是原子级的平整度。
就是原子级的平整度。
现在的所有光学系统都是以原子。
就是说我这个品面过去是吧？
它的那个高低的物差。
是一两个原子这种级别。
我的妈呀？
这让我想起来
那个小说三体里
外星人发来水滴
就是你到原子级别。
再陆续放
再放大几千几万倍。
它仅仅还是光的
还是平的
多吓人
所以我们三次在加工方面。
主要的问题是
我们无法到
这个精度
没有原子级的检测设备。
因为没有检测设备。
它就是配套的
是吧？
就是说我有个车床。
我要加工很久
我要出一个很好的零件。
是因为我的整个车床系统。
它精度很高
我就能加工起来
是吧？
我们现在杜摩也是。
我们相关的工业的大机床。
杜摩的这种检测类的。
这种配套的产业
可能无法供给到这么一个水轮。
理解了
所以其实也蛮挺痛苦的一个。
然后咱就像刚才那个。
广播导也是这问题。
现在
因为我们现在为什么能说是吧？
中美在在在这
这太能说了
在在在打架的时候。
它其实现在不光对我们。
比如说14大米以下。
对什么18到20几大米的。
光刻机也开始陆续的限制了。
就是
这个整个光刻机
现在它已经已经不只是做芯片方面的。
光电系统可能都依赖于光刻机的一些。
所以它就会越来之程越高。
就压抑整个产业人的。
成熟度
对吧？
嗯
那所以说呢？
XR刚才像那个广播导。
现在这个广播导非常贵啊？
这个一套广播导
想象的出来
现在Mata做出来。
这么一个广播导的成本。
差不多就需要799以上的每一刀。
就光一套广播导
我还不说别的计算。
这只是成本是吧？
只是成本
哦
这不是售价
你售价至少还要成个市场。
对 但是你想六七就四千多块钱。
对呀？
这个普通消费者肯定无法。
无法
这也是现在XR眼镜面临的很多的问题。
但是你像国内卖的好的那些。
它其实还是折射的。
对
它这个折射最简单是吧？
无论屏幕在上面在下面。
我一个三角形
就解决
对
然后它效率很高嘛？
就大概就50%
是吧？
嗯
你就像咱们那提此期。
我最多就消耗掉一半嘛？
因为它45度
那个光可能一半散掉了。
另外一半能折射回来是吧？
对
然后我那肚膜如果能肚的更好一些。
这球又又是肚膜
对
就又好一点
它就会更好
但是它不太好的地方。
就是它确实厚度
就配戴上了
它就
尤其是
就大家从侧面看
就是就是
如果是你们站在我这边。
你就能明显感觉那种。
那种眼镜
它是这样的
就是
你理解我的意思了吧？
是是是
突出来一块
我觉得这镜头应该能看见。
就是它这块会突出来。
它是这样的
因为它厚嘛？
对
它就是
就是你正面看
可能基本像正常眼镜。
但从侧面看
你会非常清楚的知道。
这不是一个普通的眼镜。
而且女生就
不是很喜欢
对 因为它
它配戴感觉不够
对
它一是
它对鼻梁很有电力要求。
真的
它对鼻梁有要求
这就女生不喜欢的。
因为女生爱美
你这把我两个鼻子弄得很难受。
比如说化妆
粉底上的
就是这两个
那个鼻托的位置
我带时间长了
摘下来
这就是两硬上
这个就是挺难接受的一个事。
我觉得戴音那么沉的东西。
我颈椎下不一定受得了。
我告诉你
我这个
那个可能也没那么？
比那个VR眼镜
还是要轻的
我大概能到
60克左右
对
670克
那么一个水平
但是女生肯定还是。
还是觉得
配戴感觉很差
男的也觉得配戴感差吧？
哎呀？
我们做生意的
我们肯定说还行吗？
但是我做了一个小的摸底吧？
我觉得这个事
我也跟很多从业者聊过。
就是大家现在觉得。
50克可能是个分水灵。
是
50克以上基本上是不太可能。
让普通用户长时间。
配戴的
是
哎
但是你看
咱说了半天这眼镜。
它本质上就是这个显示技术。
就是一个显示
实际上它不用承担说。
比如说我把它的计算。
那些芯片什么之类的。
放到眼镜里
那个不是特别重要的。
对吧？
我觉得现在是大家没想好。
这个事
对
没错
这个就是另外一盘了。
是吧？
我显示器现在的成熟度很差。
但是它也在往里头填内容吗？
所以现在每个眼镜上。
都做的都特别重
因为你光做眼镜
你是活不下去的
对
你给我们另外一盘在哪。
你没有另外一盘对吧？
就是现在感觉
效果不够技术来凑。
我像你这眼镜
我感觉主要都是音频功能。
这就没什么视频功能。
对
因为你比如说
你把视频对那个眼镜的整个。
不说眼镜了
你整个公司相当于运气一摊事。
对
你那个公司就会变得庞大无比。
我就个日子
比如说我们要把整个视频装进来。
你的视频源凑哪来。
IP问题解决没解决。
是吧？
然后那佩戴的感受。
然后你这个研发从光机店。
一直到内容端
甚至广告
你都需要弄整个公司。
就原来本来是一个显示器公司。
后面变成计算公司。
然后在后座变成人工智能公司。
是吧？
你就端到端全做了。
所以现在的一个问题就是。
做眼镜的公司都不是小公司。
他做的做的很大才行。
都是大厂
可能还是要主导这事。
对
这个地方其实存在一个切入的可能性。
就是
如果眼镜
既然大家的成熟度相对比较高。
那有没有可能一个厂商。
我来负责做一个眼镜的适配。
我做一个计算系统。
眼镜你就做显示器。
就跟电脑一样
眼镜做显示器
是吧？
然后我们再做一层计算。
这样子
分开产业分开
我们努力的去把计算系统做好。
你把眼镜系统做好。
然后我们一配合上内容。
显示
它就能形成原来咱们电脑这类的。
是
不应该这样
对
这不现代工业体系。
你看手机不就是这样的。
有些厂家做皮封
有些厂家做芯片
对
但是现在
就是在下一个
这个伪度的争夺战上。
大家都不愿意轻易的把。
放开
因为如果我是个做显示器的公司。
我就没有固执了
对
不性感
这个事在资本市场不性感不行。
好
那我要做计算
我就会很重
就是现在很多公司。
都是不得不做计算。
就它没有办法
我光做显示器完了。
没固执了
我融不上钱了
但是我一做计算
吧？
你计算啥呢？
你计算上就在内容。
什么AI什么一堆东西。
你就堆吧？
是吧？
这个公司就其实是。
我前端因为我克服不了的事。
我后端还要做各种。
我不太会做的事
好
那两端弄起来
这个公司就使劲烧钱。
但是你的盈喻能律。
那个眼劲的
这个盈喻能律其实也是很受限。
可能大家一开始都是还是。
我说这个经济就是北京豆汁经济。
就是什么呢？
哎
每个人过来都尝一嘴。
然后下次喝
就这样了
对
大家都属于还好奇。
我是经常喝
对对
反正过来
你家人太少了
很少有豆汁回头喝。
就是豆汁经济
就是过来
每个人都尝一嘴
其实量也不少
对吧？
但是说我留下来
天天能喝那些人可能就。
不见得很多
因为现在使用体验上。
我觉得能让我留下来的理由。
还不是很多
对
几乎没有
往往就是说
这能录音翻译一下。
是吧？
就起到一个耳机的作用。
对
视频呢？
你看它如果再接拍。
录点小段子
其实可以
但是现在它
又录的比较短
是吧？
只能录几十秒
关于视频这个事
我自己有一些消费端的体验。
因为刚才其实张老师说的。
一个特别重要的问题。
就是我们视觉体系其实是两路。
然后在我们的人左右眼。
看到的东西
在大脑当中
它自动拼成一个完整的图像。
对吧？
现在绝大多数的AI眼镜。
尤其是带两颗摄像头的眼镜。
它也是这么思考这个问题的。
所以它在左右边各给大家。
设置了一个摄像头。
对
但这个有几个需要解决的。
现在解决的不好的技术问题。
比如说还是以女孩子为例。
你如果把这两颗眼的摄像头放在左右两端。
我这个头发俩只要稍微一滴头。
它就废了
它就挡上了
就是这个事你很难拿。
你想把它作为生产力工具。
你看没头发还有好处了。
真是
嗨
我就没有这困扰
我第一次发现我也有。
就真的
这个事我看没有人提过。
我也是无意当中发现的。
还有另外的一个事就是。
因为我们为了让外挂的设备变轻。
所以它这个摄像头它的画质就很一般。
它很一般到什么程度了。
它几乎做不到防抖。
当然从软件上
它可以形成一些防抖的算法。
但它本质上还是不太防抖。
所以你就会发现你录出来的东西。
我的天
我才知道原来人脑这么晃。
你怎么知道人脑又跟鸡头不一样。
鸡头又个稳定鸡头。
你人脑怎么那么晃。
而且这个视角太高了。
就是戴在头上
这个角度拍出来的画面。
你会觉得就跟你肉眼看到的。
它不是一个方向
它不太是一个高度。
因为人的眼球能动。
对
是吗？
眼球是能上下移动的。
对
还是人的这套原生的领奖。
整个计算系统好
对
这个计算系统特别棒。
现在有一些厂家在解决这个问题。
比如雷鸟
他做了一个设计
就是他只在我们印堂的这个位置。
装一颗上头
但一颗上头
你看又回到了我们一直说的。
它又不立体
对吧？
它又是二地的
所以现在我觉得戴上头。
截止到我们今天录节目这一天。
它就是一个完成的不好的产品。
没错
几乎不可用
当然你说我拍一张照片。
拍30秒视频
你说是不是
反正总归我们做媒体的。
就是这素材肯定有比没有强。
对
但它确实不好用
数量比较低
它确实不好使
人的这个脑袋其实最大的问题是。
它不是一个特别好的云台。
相当不好
对
它是个不好的云台。
所以我们大脑是怎么在里面那个。
其实你没感觉
我们自己
你真的露出来
你会发现
怎么那么坏
它在同一个角度
它绝对
连一两秒它都戴不住。
戴不住
到处看是吧？
对
在眼天里边你就看。
突然羡慕起气了
什么？
好奇害死猫是吧？
你那个人的那个计算。
因为他计算能力很强。
他就
他那个目光
他不是堆着一个点看。
他可能到处看
对
然后他每一个点
可能就落那么一两秒钟。
他就跳
你出来那个
你在小屏上看
比如说这还行
还凑合事
你要放在一个电视上。
你马上就云彩了
我有一个
你看我们外行
就是胜在可以歧思妙想。
有没有可能就眼镜这个主意。
就是个坏主意
就不是个好主意
比如刚才咱谈到
除了眼镜
另一个思路是脑袋接口。
对吧？
脑袋接口
当然我们对他可能还有一些担忧。
但是也不是只有脑袋接口。
比如说我纯外行的那个。
我们如果想实现
随时在眼前的持续的显示。
甭管是AR或者VR。
有没有可能是通过释网膜。
或者侵入试神经来解决这个问题。
就是我不是侵入大脑。
但是我接入一个东西。
到试神经或者在试网膜。
戴个美铜
或者眼球美铜
对
就是他把显示这部分给解决了。
至于什么摄像头
什么什么那个音频。
就戴个耳机
或者像警察叔叔
那执法记录一挂胸口就得了。
也许他不是非得
弄到这眼镜上
对
其实这个
你看你去试试吧？
把张老师的谈骗费了。
就把CPU打冒烟了。
不是
我因为我不知道有没有人。
我不知道有没有人去尝试这些奇怪的。
黑镜里反正有
是吗？
有吗？
其实人的这个眼睛。
最重要的一个问题。
是他的标准化不是特别好。
他除了大小的飞标。
他有近视的飞标
色度的飞标等等等等。
无路的飞标
对
而现在这个眼镜在这种飞标上解决。
还算是相对标准化。
你要是往里头去清。
可能千人千变
你标准化的产品可能就又废了。
因为你比如说你往这儿嫁。
他还是标准化的东西。
你往里头在
稍微往里头一清入。
咱都不说物理
现在供电什么的
是吧？
你还有
你不可能甩出他两根电线吧？
他要效果自备好
我就愿意甩
现在甩
我没事儿捋着玩
他来
然后
都有头发
这两根
哎呦
他毛少
从去去
然后
像他在什么曲度
曲度
什么他的度数
你的眼睛见球
大小覆盖度
等等等等
难度更高
这样千人千变
这个标准品可能会更难一点。
就说到底还是一个。
工业体系的问题
是
就是
我们刚才说了那么多。
你会发现
虽然现在眼镜已经很红火了。
但是眼镜后边的工业体系。
其实是有一部分借鉴了手机的。
现在有很多手机的工业上。
比如说瑞生
他在做一部分眼镜的业务。
像戈尔
他也在做一部分眼镜的业务。
他其实都是
从过去手机的工业链里。
择出来的
现在线拼成
眼镜可能整个工业体系。
还不够成熟
应该没有市场的支撑。
以后足够成熟了
可能像刚才我们说的这些问题。
都得以解决
工业体系真的是太重要了。
我就稍微讲一个小故事。
是我最近才知道的。
咱们几个应该都经历过此代时期。
对吧？
经历过
虽然有点显老
但是经历过
对
就像我
我拒绝都不合适
但是我真不知道
我们的听众朋友
是不是经历过此代时期。
现在有很多high-five厂商。
他们在尝试做什么？
他们在尝试复刻此代机。
他们发现
你就别看
这离我们二三十年前的产品。
复刻起来就非常的难。
磁头做不出来
磁头做不出来了
做不出来
你没想到吧？
就是咱们都
工业发展的都已经。
化成人类璀璨的明珠了。
居然复刻不
对
因为没有那套工业体系了。
所以做不出来
对
你任何一工业体系。
只要它不做了
就没了
那我家里那两岁人听我。
我得保护
值钱了
真是值钱了
你这笔口
诚实量太大了
这种东西
我就挨的
赶紧改了
真的
而且现在的问题是这样的。
就是刚才刘鹏老师说的一特对。
就是现在此代
它一定是个非常小众的市场。
对吧？
这一波小众市场
又不可能足以说
让我们重建一套工业体系。
那厂商在生产产品的时候。
他也要考量成本
他说我这机器
我只能卖500块钱。
那我的成本就只能控制在200以内。
200块钱的成本。
我怎么说服工业练书。
你给我复刻一个
八九十年代之前的磁头。
这可以不计成本的做。
那不可能
不计成本这件事
只在小说里出现
是的
所以这就是整个工业体系的加持。
对
尤其工业体系不支持它的整个。
你比如像美国登月。
也是相同的问题
对
是时间太久了
是吧？
是真的
不是他不想他有很多是隐性知识。
并不是都看手册就能做。
他们根本就不会等了。
这次绕一圈也是费半天进。
是吧？
就相当于一带人走了。
剩下的就是不弄
不会了
这就是人类很奇怪的事情。
人类那个智慧
它知识是可以流传千年万年的。
因为它我写在纸上。
知识
它智慧流传不下去。
像这种工业体系
它可能就是当时的智慧的一个结晶。
你过了也就过了
你走
都把他争流伤skill就行了。
我觉得很难得
有些东西真的是
非常强的
那个不可描述的经验性。
是
能说登月了
这美国做那个M.E.A.R.坦克。
那个现在都做不了了。
它底盘剩多少就是多少了。
是
你一个再七个新的都做不出来。
就那套生产线已经没有了。
是
工人也都没有了
想再找一找不回来。
就是一带工程是
就对
真的就是这样
所以死亡是宇宙送给人类。
很美好的礼物
是
真的真的
真的
你想
是这样的
Restart一下。
这是一哲学命运
所以现在
让我聊沉默了
像现在的眼镜
我们在做的时候
我们公司为什么在做的时候。
当然我们还是想解决。
把它分开的问题
但是在行业
比如说我把计算
眼睛分开这个事情。
刚才跟许老师我们一讨论。
你看其实也有问题就是。
我们在
在捣乱整个估值体系。
这肯定不健康
对吧？
你竟然在战
杀人家最大一块蛋糕。
所以我们其实做这个事。
在眼镜这件事情上。
我们公司的切入点。
也确实是有点
诺屁吸睛
但是你不这么切也没有办法。
为什么呢？
因为
它眼镜的成熟度
比如说一个阶段的成熟度。
已经OK了
你不能因为没有计算系统。
眼镜就没法卖是吧？
总有人出来
就要给它做一个计算系统。
这样眼镜内容它配套的。
然后因为现在眼镜。
各种的这种问题
所以我们也是选择一些。
图大B的一些场景去做。
比如说小B或者C的市场。
哪一天是不是能用上这个技术。
我也不太确定
但至少说
我觉得眼镜
站往后那么一两代了之后。
它这个体验应该还是不错的。
因为我现在外体验。
我配戴了Mata那块。
相对下一代的显示系统。
它算贵
它确实体验还是不错的。
Mata那有多沉。
Mata那个就很轻。
但是好消息是
它下一代确实做的很轻。
但是这个坏消息是。
Mata在眼镜这一部分的投入。
现在是越来越少了。
对
因为这样没市场对它来说。
它现在把OE&A害了。
所以这两块蛋糕
它不可能一起骑
因为这两个都是实在都特别烧钱的。
先Mata很多的经济放在AI上。
眼镜这一端就像徐老师说的。
整个产业量
其实都是被Mata往前推。
推完然后大家变现一下。
推一下
大家变现一下
但当它这个大哥不使劲推的时候。
变现能力就会有可能会下降。
对
那谁去推呢？
然后国内谁能成为。
比如说在眼镜这个世界真正的一个推手。
这还都是问题
有道理
对
因为现在推还是投入为主。
实际上回报是
看不到
不是短期能看得见的。
对
你像Mata这种企量。
是万一级别的公司。
你推一个这种市场。
都已经推成这样了。
如此真难
你更别说国内一个估值几个亿。
十几个亿的一个小公司。
在推这市场
然后你可能就是杯水车薪。
根本可能没什么希望。
我最近用了一个
我是觉得
你看我用了市场主流的眼镜之后。
我不是选了这个吗？
但我最近用了一个。
我是觉得至少能让我眼前一亮的。
是X-Rail在海外发了。
在国内现在还没发的。
跟华硕合作的一个电镜AR眼镜。
那个眼镜是我截止到目前试下来。
它也是那种
我们说的折射的那种方式的。
它从侧面看
说实话
我觉得厚度已经控制得还行了。
但还是厚
它在厚的里面算控制得还行。
但那个眼镜有个特别大的优点。
就是它的延时度的足够低。
所以你戴上
它主打电镜
所以就是你戴上眼镜。
你就可以打游戏了。
我觉得这个场景还是切得比较真实。
又因为
跟不大眼镜有什么区别打游戏。
还是那游戏本身就是一三滴的。
游戏本身是个三滴的。
是三滴的
它就相当于如果你没有电脑的时候。
你没有打游戏的场景的时候。
你就可以戴上这个眼镜。
你就可以沉浸式的打游戏。
因为它会投出来一个大屏。
那个画质非常厉害。
因为它们用的那个。
对
它们用的那个芯片也是索尼的。
就MicroLED。
是现在最好的显示芯片了。
显示面板
就它们用的全套设备都非常好。
而且那个延时控制的非常低。
我大概那天试了又20分钟。
说实话
这是很少见的
我没有感觉到头晕和恶心的。
这是我截至到目前。
我觉得试的还不错的一个。
多少钱
7000多吧？
我怎么记得还没公布售价。
对至少我觉得
不便宜
它一定便宜不了
因为MicroLED它的成本本上就非常高。
一块100寸的MicroLED的电视。
两年前是卖100多万。
是
所以那块小屏是非常贵的。
对
因为它够亮
它特别亮
它MicroLED的发光原理。
它为什么能做这么亮。
自发光
因为它上头每个灯泡。
它上头每个像素像的灯泡。
我就能让它亮度放得很亮。
像咱们这种显示器。
它是个背板
然后通过前面过滤。
过滤出来这种光
所以你就有个问题。
你过滤它又有效率问题。
就是一个黑是特别。
一个黑就是黑
一个黑它不是黑
一个黑其实是它闭合了之后。
后面的灯还亮了
这就是LCD和OLED的区别。
所以OLED它就像灯珠。
可以做特别特别亮。
然后它整个色彩的还原度。
就是红
到底有多红
蓝
到底有多蓝
它又会做的会比普通的那些做的好很多。
但就是你想方寸之间。
一个像素都是压好米像素的这种。
是吧？
就是几个微米
就是成本
其实它这个贵主要是因为它卖的少。
对呀？
并不是因为说它
对
它太小众了
它就必然贵
是的
导致它就更卖不出去。
这就是世界上最大的问题。
就是机和单单和机的问题。
对
你这儿
那儿是吧？
你这儿贵因为卖不出去。
你说我打卖得出去呢？
你得便宜
这就蓝回绕
这个圈
大家其实都在这个诡异的圈子里头绕来绕去。
是没有办法
其实现在眼镜也陷入到这么一很诡异的圈子。
眼镜整体市场都比较小是吧？
现在还
去年卖了全球
我看了一下
就是去年差不多卖了100多万部吧？
嗯
100多万
那不多
那从全球市场来看。
真不多
相当小
你别比手机
觉得很小众的手机品牌都比较多。
非常小众了
比手机动不动几十亿部的出货量。
对吧？
你这么一笔眼镜确实是卖的非常少。
像手机一年出货量。
可能就过异了
对过异
对
巅峰的时候可能几十亿吧？
现在估计也就是几亿。
十几亿那样
所以你从眼镜
但是眼镜大家都认为是下代的计算系统。
嗯
所以呢？
大家还是想去卡计算。
嗯
他的计算将来这个端是不是还是得放的。
上手机这种设备上。
比较可行
嗯
因为我要带着出去溜的。
可能也没法带一个计算设备。
他这个是吧？
这个计算的眼镜啊？
其实最后还是两个问题。
一个是功耗
一个是价格
你放在眼镜上的设计算。
我觉得功耗要求太高了。
但是你比如说你拆出来。
这就行业里头叫尿袋。
就是
背着一盒子
你背一个盒子这种。
手机是有可能的
就是你手机他不是眼镜也挂在手机上吧？
这种形态反而
我们就叫这种形态叫尿袋嘛？
我们iPhone用户谁不知道什么是尿袋。
哈哈哈哈
对这种形态
大家就感觉不是很爽。
是相当不实
有没有可能通过无线的方式解决。
就是我如果是很高清的视频可能不行。
但其他的计算任务是可以的。
都不行我觉得
因为要用蓝牙
不确定要用蓝牙
因为你的手机是可以开热点的。
是可以走
你热点跟你两个手机带宽是非常快的。
这个技术是现成的。
哦
刘老师说的是那种类似于L-Job一类的技术。
这就有一个问题啊？
就是说如果你是端到端的头。
如果你比如说手机连到我这个眼镜。
它是没有IP问题的。
哦
是吧？
刘老师你知道我的意思吗？
但是你要说我的手机的那种头在我眼睛端。
这是个头的问题
你就会有IP问题了。
就因为每个端它都会生成一个地址。
对你这个内容是不是能和。
你比如说很多咱们电视上是。
不能说你手机头的电视上去看片。
但是你这个头这个技术不是存在吗？
但这不是个技术问题了。
对
但是它会限制你端的能力。
说你是不是能头
对
你要不能头
你内容又没了
你自己做内容
那不就更废了
天呐
真的
我都没想到这里边还有这么多事。
是吧？
你就有很多它其实产品端到细节上。
它可能
任何一块半角石
你前面白看
就只有您这类做产品的人。
才能想到这么多细节。
其实我们更多的还是看体验的。
是
反正它有很多这种问题。
其实根本上就是我们。
要解决内容和观看者之间的关系。
但是随意中间就是各种。
这就是那盘粗
那就开始
哎呀？
就各种做
一会儿这不行了
我们再换一个思路。
做着做着连最开始做的兄弟都忘了。
说哎呦
我要干啥呢？
就是这样吗？
对
做着最后说你看
这个干脆做成耳机算不起了。
就我们真是咋做个耳机。
挂上屋也行吗？
现在很多的眼镜本身就是耳机。
对
我最后选了这个
其实也是出于这个考量。
就那儿
因为说实话
我之所以选这个
一是我觉得这个外形还挺好看的。
第二个原因
还真不是耳机
是因为它轻
就我这个东西
它虽然有耳机的功能。
但它二十多克
这是截止到目前
我试着所有眼镜产品里最轻的。
而且也好看
因为我过去就提出过。
给所有给我产品的甲方。
我都提出一个问题。
我说我是一个不戴眼镜的人。
我说你们的这个产品。
得做到多牛
才能让我一个不戴眼镜的人。
把这个眼镜给戴上。
你们这个理由给我的充分不充分。
好
然后我近视了
哎呀真的是牛马呀？
一语乘乘
你就是为眼镜而胜。
哪一天近视
不是哪一天近视
这个事是这样的
就是我过去没有在意过这个事。
我过去还老吹牛
我说我呀？
罗眼视力一直一点二。
最后一行一直能看清。
突然这两年体检的时候。
就发现右眼依然很清楚。
左眼就不太行
对
左眼就看不清
一开始我没当回事。
这不是现在开始研究眼镜了吗？
经常接触一些眼镜的眼科医生。
然后我就问他们
我说我这个情况到底是咋回事。
需不需要干预
他们说你这个叫趋光不正。
但最终促使我把眼镜戴上。
是有一个晏光师问了我一句话。
说你日常走路摔跤吗？
完
我日常走路真的很容易。
比如说路上有个
就是那个翘起来的那个小石板。
就特别容易摘
特别容易摔跤
后来我就发现
就是因为我的大脑。
他其实接受到的
只是一边眼镜的信息。
因为你左边眼镜给他传递的信息。
是模糊的
他就自动屏蔽了
他就不用
那时候如果你想要干预这种情况。
就跟你长短腿一样。
最好还是干预一下。
好 戴上了
我是一直
坚持着呢？
我眼睛一直很好
用不坏的
就很奇怪
这话我是想说
所以刚才您这个
就启发了
你看
我是不应该去做眼镜。
然后后来选了这个。
就是因为我觉得
他架点鼻梁上
你别说
还是挺方便
就是偶尔听个东西什么的。
你不用再从包里把耳机翻出来。
然后再戴上
然后又
你这得充电
对 充电
但他截至到目前
就是我是觉得
功耗还控制得不错。
至少一天半左右
才需要充一次
而且他充电的效率很高。
就他整个能源管理。
我觉得管的还是不错的。
但是整个不需要把。
眼镜吸到哪
还是他后面有一根。
对
他就这个眼镜腿两端是触点。
就通过这两端去
把电源充上就行了。
然后在这个眼镜腿两端。
是有能看得出来
这个扬声器的这个口。
就不放弃的这个
可是你用它
不管是听任何音频的内容。
难道不会
就是私密性很差吗？
就是你在
这个事我也考虑过。
就是坦白讲
就是我在戴这个的过程当中。
我觉得它声音外阔。
控制的还是不错的。
就是比如说咱们这种。
这种距离
对就是漏音
刘鹏老师应该是能听见。
但听不清
所以他其实在
这个就属于音频行业的技术了。
就咱们现在音频行业。
在这方面什么主动降噪。
包括什么过滤噪音。
这其实已经定向的。
这个喇叭
已经做得很好了
像他这个可能在定向上。
定向的就很好
对
就我们相当于这个声音。
是跟气泡一样的能改。
明白
他就控制这个气泡的传播方向。
就像咱们这个麦克风一样。
你这么说话
他能收进去
旁边收不进去
是的
他就有一个指向性。
对
所以我觉得还行
就是这个眼镜是给了我。
可用的这个体验的。
别的眼镜
我觉得更多的是新鲜。
对
但这个确实就是一个耳机。
它对我来说就是耳机。
跟眼镜合成体
很多做眼镜的
最后其实这个
就是眼镜这个产业。
它分出很多
比如说很多做眼镜的。
最后去做那个
车载的抬头险去了。
HOD
对
其实这两个技术是。
很像的
很像
就是基本都是就是。
所以你不是说做眼镜这个产业。
这样它
这其实也是很多伟大公司。
我觉得应该做的事情。
它就使劲把这个
车轮往前推
对
然后推下来的一些。
泥巴什么种子
它混合在一块
它可能长出别的肘。
对
这我觉得
比如说像未来
可能近视眼镜也有福音了。
我们可能用1毫米走的这个镜片。
能解决所有是
那个近视眼镜的问题。
是吧？
然后像这种
比如说
车载的AR抬头险。
提磁器
各种的这种东西
可能都因为这个东西。
但是它可能解决
在解决这个终极问题。
比如说进入式的
体验这件事情
可能它还是一直做不好。
它可能能做好了很多其他事。
那比如说它往前推。
我们这个阶段
我们说
它缺内容
我们2D3D给它供一下。
是吧？
眼睛佩戴也还可以。
我们选一些场景
别让人一边走一边看。
是吧？
比如说我们把这固定刀。
什么按摩椅上
这些场景上
是吧？
然后它可能
打游戏
这些场景上
我们把这种
内容给它3D画了之后。
它能坐在那
然后甚至于有一些倾斜角度。
是吧？
小女生
你不是压的感受
我们只要有个地方能倾斜。
这样有足够的空间。
去打翻那些剩余时间的时候。
这个场景
可能就长了
可能坐不大
但是它能形成一些。
此场画的东西就行。
如果它的内容3D画的东西。
能解决
尽管是固定在那
我也觉得
这个市场是挺大的。
对
对吧？
关键是内容真正高质量的。
三位那种非常非常少。
对
是吧？
苹果出的时候
我觉得它这个产品。
就是因为这件事
没有能够
没有能够走下去
对
现在苹果
其实也希望说我们。
你看它出的手机
现在有两个摄像机。
它有一个手机
是有华为的手机
它有两个摄像机
可以直接派出空间视频来。
苹果的现在也行了。
对
它派那个空间视频。
其实就是在为它的眼镜。
投险服务
但是还是那个问题。
就是
你这整个传播的这些路径。
你觉得那种惨了就行了。
对吧？
没人看
好
你传播怎么传
我举个例子
你要传播还是用原来的信道去传。
原来的信道
它不止是3D的传播。
你发微博上没有用。
而且就是我
大家有没有发现
最近这几年
院线里边的3D电影。
越来越少了
你都想不起来这个事了。
对
当年有几年
任何电影
进电院
先发电影就好
对
现在去电影院
3D电影可越来越少了。
我感觉就是大家慢慢发现。
它那个东西是3D的还是2D的。
对于那个娱乐性
基本上没有什么大的影响。
我也觉得比如说日常。
现在大家刷个短视频。
那些日常拍摄的短视频。
那些搞笑的内容
是2D 3D区别真不大。
对
其实这是内容的两个伪度。
一个是内容说
我在内容的这个品质上。
我更清楚
比如说2K 4K 8K是吧？
这更清楚
真据更高
更丝滑是吧？
然后2D 3D
我让它体验感更好。
这是内容的一个伪度。
另外一个伪度是什么？
有趣
好
你会发现
在有趣的内容面前。
那些内容都无所谓。
对
技术都无所谓
这就干了
现在你比如说你抖音什么的。
大家习惯于
它并不是说
院线的3D电影犯什么错误。
是
大家欣赏有趣的东西的。
这个及时感要求很高。
我没有耐心当电影员。
我享受一个90分钟。
120分钟的这个沉浸感。
是不是
它是花花刷手机
我嗨了
你这影片过两天
到我手机上
就五分钟
我就看完了
我折腾
我去你刚转两个小时干什么？
是的
这是折行业
那你如果
我说如果
我在新上短视频的时候。
我们也可以让它更清楚。
也可以让它体验更好。
这就我们做这件事情的一个想法。
我们无论它是清晰度。
帧率更高
然后二地三地
它只是一个表象
把这个东西架在谁身上。
这件事情更重要
我们肯定选择
把这种更好的技术。
架在更好的内容上。
是吧？
那这样子
它更好的内容就更有章率。
我们其实就是为了让更好的内容。
能让大家在新上的结果上。
更好一点
就解决这么一点点事情。
然后有一些
比如说资产化的一个变现。
就完了
其实技术其实最后它的服务点。
你很难说我去解决。
但是端到端的问题。
其实我们还是更关注说优质的内容。
来自于哪
然后我们把相关的一些技术。
架在优质的内容上。
来实现一个更高效率的。
变伤天花
对
我听刚才咱聊这话。
对我突然想起一些网试。
什么网试
我200几年开始。
就进广告公司写文案了。
我写过手机的广告。
也写过电视的广告。
就真的是200几年的时候。
就写某国国内大品牌电视的广告。
最早的功能手机和智能手机的广告。
我都写过
《森林奇境》这个词。
在当时各种广告里边不断的出现。
说我们说超大40英寸的。
那个屏幕的电视
让你《森林奇境》
对吧手机屏幕
当时你想那功能机的手机屏幕能不能多大。
《森林奇境》
《森林奇境》这个词。
在各种广告宣传里边。
已经被用了不知道多少年了。
是吧？
我们小时候买一29寸的电视。
那时候都说《森林奇境》
实际上就好像大家一直把《森林奇境》
描述当成一个非常理想的。
体验
美好的
大家都期望得到的体验。
晚点
我自己对这个是有反思的。
就是大家
我当时写的时候就想。
第一 这玩意儿真能《森林奇境》吗？
第二 就是大家真需要《森林奇境》吗？
不太需要
我相信在智能眼镜的年代。
这个问题还应该被认真的考虑一下。
那我正好最近有一个类似的思考。
就是跟眼镜关系不大。
但可能跟这种感知的关系有点大。
因为你看现在人工智能如此。
昌明发展的
长绝
你这事好
对
就是他能干好多好多事。
但我反而觉得
就像我们这种面对面的沟通跟交流。
按你跟朋友去听一场现场的演唱会。
你们俩手拉手一起欢呼。
我反而觉得这种人与人之间。
真实的这种接触就显得特宝贵。
我昨天
对
我就觉得好宝贵
而且我觉得他们完全不能替代。
我听过很多人最近几年再说。
真实会变成一个非常稀缺。
又珍贵的东西
我昨天在网上看到。
就是大家把它当做一个。
科技造福人类的新案例来说的。
两个那个年轻人要结婚了。
他们拒绝了
影楼开出来的成千上万的那个。
婚纱照的拍摄的方案。
两个包给生成了一张。
两个人自己随便拍了一张居家的自拍。
交给AI
AI给生成了非常精美的。
在什么希腊的
在东南亚的
在哪哪哪的
精美的婚纱照
大家都暂探不已
说你看AI造福人类。
生成了那么精美的照片。
确实你看起来它很像。
很真
二十年前十几年前。
那些花高价拍出来的婚纱照。
但我看的时候真有一个想法。
就是当他们二十年后回头看这一组。
用AI生成的假的婚纱照的时候。
他会什么感觉
他会感动吗？
他会心喜吗？
还是说他们反倒会拿着那个手机。
拍成的
他俩那张原始的自拍。
会带给他们更多的感动。
是
这个说道了
我觉得是很哲学的一个东西。
就是很人性和很神性的一些东西。
我因此最近觉得
我要不以后学个按摩师吧？
功能都被取得
真是
我给我儿子的建议就包括这一点。
我觉得按摩师特好。
但可能不太适合女性。
因为这个指节
我们的指节可能不太好。
都考虑这么细了
我是认真的
这都已经准备开始从业了。
指甲做感觉
他觉得按摩不行
可能爱丘师还可以考虑。
我给我儿子的建议包括按摩。
包括修空调
是吧修锁
就是这种需要去现场操作。
并且就必须到场的。
以及有具体人和人接触的。
这样的工作
我觉得未来应该挺稀缺的。
是
我同意
这个我同意
其实就是科技
我前两天就是看东老师发了一条微博。
我觉得特别有趣
他说我发的那么有趣呢？
他说20年前我年轻。
可能你不是这么说的。
但是我大概意思就说自己原来。
在地铁里的时候
也被人称之为是小皇帝。
我不是在地铁里被人称为小皇帝。
那是在哪
我说的是我在地铁里看到一堆。
愁眉苦脸的中年人。
啊对对对对
我就想起来
就我们这帮80后啊？
小时候那些什么报纸新闻里都说。
说这是一代小皇帝。
对因为活得太好了。
就交生快养的小皇帝。
独生子女嘛？
你想那个时候
我们在看20年的时代。
我们就觉得那日子得多美啊？
是吧？
你看车发展成什么样了。
电脑发展成什么样。
电话发展成什么样了。
后面都现在就这么点。
功能这么高级
但你的幸福指数提升了吗？
我没觉得
这个不会提升的
以前咱们聊过这话。
提升了
那个哪个老师
因为这很简单的道理。
你的那个你分泌那多巴胺。
那个化学那物质动态范围就那么大。
你再这么提升
他也是分泌那点东西。
所以你说人类
就非常简单那一套。
你说咱干嘛呢？
你说人类的前途在于化学。
是不是
对
这如果能再聊就危险了。
这得真得掐了
真掐不了
后面这段就很危险了。
这不能再说了这个。
这可以消音
今天得亏没有
我们有直播
直播毁了
这关键全完了
但是我觉得刚才你说的那个真实的东西。
我觉得年轻人他可能不一定这么想。
他看的虚拟
你听我说就是我
很多现在年轻的小朋友。
为什么他们一定要抢那个票去。
看现场的演唱会
去见他的idol。
他作为一个closer。
他必须要去现场的那个漫展和种种活动。
这个真实感
恐怕没有那么快被人类抛弃。
我不是说真实感没价值。
我是说虚拟的东西真正价值。
不在于像那个
你说的婚纱照
那模拟真实的东西。
他在于超越真实的东西。
有道理
就我同意
你们说漫剧这东西。
你觉得漫剧的东西。
就比真人拍的招人。
招人戏来
为什么？
他狗血
你真人拍不了那么狗血。
自己
还是谎言
是
他在于超越真实性。
你模拟真实性是没有任何意义。
是很难
是
你很难让人
比如说AI出来这个影片。
目前那种真实性还是有问题。
但是
因为
他不需要真实性
他需要更狗血
我们做计算的
所以我们相对来说。
对这个世界看上去更冷血一些。
真是这样
因为你无法抽象
你就无法去计算
计算都是一堆公式。
他很冷冰冰的
你比如说我们现在对普通的人。
这个人生是有定义的。
比如说
一个普通的人生
只有四体的数据
你没听错
一个很普通的人生。
大概只有四个体的数据。
就能把你的一生给存出来。
这数据包括哪些呢？
就是你的图像
你的声音
你的微流
就很普通的人生
就是练画
就是四个体
我练画就四个体
就完事了
天呐
像徐老师
大威
我们往高率说
五十个体
这么多
太高了
我不信
但是
我说出来
这个比如说几十个体。
大家这个感觉说
哦
三块硬盘啊？
哎
这感觉太
我脑子已经想象出。
您已经知道我的意思了。
知道
所以呢？
我们现在其实对人的这样话是。
是很冷血的
这也是我们为什么？
是我们为什么要去做。
AI的一个原因啊？
就是我们公司
那是一套计算系统。
是吧？
他只是比如说放在屋子里头。
他
他在采集我们的事。
我们的
我们这套东西
他现在不是一套
直播
说路过设备
你可以把它当作一套。
视觉采集设备
他在采集我们每个人的人生。
哎
知道我意思吗？
我脑子里幻想出来的是。
那个金脚大王
金脚大王的葫芦
对
我们下一趴呢？
这个这个
这个计算的
这个未来呢？
我们就还是希望说。
我们能数字化认识。
啊？
这只是一个入口是吧？
你和这台设备中间。
就像一个镜子
你看到说里头还有一个你。
现在不是已经开始有人。
就是一比一赴源
那个果营的大脑了吗？
对
是的
我看到那个
我们也希望
不是我们希望
这是我们在
愿景
我们公司的愿景
就是说在
在在这个
这个你的镜像这一块。
有一个
有一个未来
我前一段时间
有有一两个礼拜
我沉迷于用那个
AI捏自己的视频嘛？
天天发
然后我还有一个朋友。
他把他的那个音频。
我不知道他是用什么技术。
就是现在有很多平台。
已经可以
有人用他的声音去做。
AI配音了
可以
然后我就跟他聊这事。
他就跟我说
他说我已经那个赛博永生了。
我想还真是的
就是现在像我这种。
把自己的人脸形象。
交给了某个AI平台。
事实上就是
如果我开放全线
任何人都可以用我的形象。
去灭视频出来
他已经在某种程度上。
实现了赛博永生了。
如果像您说的
把我那4T数据
再交出去
您是50T
我得50T
我再多点
我57、58、58。
对 就是那些数据。
如果真的都交出去。
好像啊？
就是这些技术
其实差不多都成熟了。
就我们这一代人
已经能赶上赛博永生的那个。
肯定是
这是肯定的
因为我就在做这件事。
因为我们为什么要把这个设备。
端话就是
你不希望你的数据。
被别人烂用是吧？
那你最好把你的数据端话。
就是你每天
这就是你那个私人资产。
你可以把它Open。
但是它有个物理按钮是吧？
你可以选择拒绝
对 我也可以通过这个物理按钮。
把所有东西的影像都给删了。
不至于说你的这个资产被。
被匀化
被匀化是一个很可怕的。
就是你其实你是控制不了的。
对
你就是像徐老师是吧？
像
我早都已经放弃了。
对对对
你只是选择是和不是。
你一试
马上这个网上的
对
我觉得这件事甚至是不可避免的。
它因为我们在做
对
就是我也是从业者之间。
我也在做这件事情。
所以这件事情你是。
我们把物理世界的人。
数字化这件事情
是你是你是没有办法。
这就是这个时代的潮流。
哎 有没有能能让肉身稍微活长一点。
办法
这别老琢磨数字了。
我现在老担心这
这天天熬夜加班
不太早走
脆胸筋还没回上
最终能多活点
这是另一问题了
我觉得人的肉身已经活得够长的了。
按照古遍的自然规律。
你到青春期
这个两倍到三倍的年龄。
多数动物也就活得不长。
不是咱技术都如此。
唱绝了
还不能让我多活多。
现在是不是也是可以的。
我不太清楚
说是一百多吧？
对
还是想点化学的办法。
现在可能就是比较贵吧？
是吧？
应该是
还多挣钱
但是好像这件事情。
现在应该是也是OK的。
张耳刚说的一个话题。
其实让我挺
怎么说呢？
就是我最近刚意识到这个事。
做技术的人
其实看待AI能不能取代人。
这件事是非常悲观的。
我最近跟几个做智能驾驶。
包括做芯片的几个。
这个悲观指的是
什么个悲观
对 哪边算悲观
就是人一定会被AI灭。
那最乐观
对技术的乐观
这不是乐观吗？
对我这一派就是悲观。
因为刚刚那句话就典型我了。
就是因为他们认为。
跟代码打交道
他们觉得数字世界跟人是平等的。
说不上谁取代谁
怎么着你们人就得是主宰。
我们数字
我们零一零一零一。
怎么了
我们就低你们一头。
只是你们人觉得自己牛逼。
人家数字世界
人家觉得工程代码什么这些。
人家也很厉害
我听完他这个说辞。
我就突然觉得
我们过去还是自持过高了。
就人还是自持过高。
这是一种宗教式的信仰。
觉得人是万物领长。
比其他动物都高
其实这也没有什么现实的基础。
但是可是
就是这是之前至少是几百年里。
这是人类的共识
就人文主义
对人类文明是建立在这个基础上的。
如果说现在把这个事否定了。
太可怕了
那这一个
完全整个世界
很多事是完全是要颠覆的。
其实人在试图
你比如说咱们从人类历史上。
我们就一直有各种的这种神文化。
所以这其实
这件事情是刻在我们基因里头的。
一段代码
我们要么就去崇拜神。
我们要么我们就去造神。
你没有办法
就像人喜欢金字一样的。
你就你从出生的时刻。
他就喜欢这个东西。
他都是发自
是吧？
他就跟吃喝拉撒睡一样的。
没有办法
所以你没有办法去阻止人去。
把他那个神给创造出来。
这个你没有办法
就总有人去干这事。
无非就是谁
是吧？
他总有一天
现在这个苗头
现在就是
就就就现在这个苗头。
就很很很属于很激进了。
现在就是不是说
是不是能创造出来。
就是哪一天出来
对
现在就是非常激进。
我前两天重读了
我现在工作的那家公司叫独库。
我们这独库
2017年发表过一篇文章。
作者是一美国人
叫team urban。
那篇文章的名字
就叫未来的人
会是怎样的
他当时去探访了
他谈的是脑机接口。
他去探访了马斯克的团队。
和马斯克本人
那是2017年的一篇文章。
但是你看当时的
那个认识和当时的。
他们那个团队对未来的设想。
以及这个作者的观察。
就已经跟您说的是差不多的了。
就是这个
这个不是一个是不是的问题。
就是一个什么时候的问题。
实际上就是一个节奏。
快一点和慢一点的问题。
因为我毕竟也是从业者。
这个技术的这个
这个往前滚的这个。
关键是现在他突破了。
原来的那种
比如说计算的瓶颈。
对
他突破这瓶颈就很可怕。
现在就是有些人说说。
得亏我没去学那个技术。
因为我等一等
我就可以可能不用学了。
那个技术过两天
他可能就更新换
但比如说小龙虾
你前面这你没学是吧？
太好了
不用学了
你也不学了
我就能学了
他过时了
但也不用学了
下一代龙虾都出来了。
下一代不是那个
什么？
Hermes吗？
那个那个叫
就新一代的那个龙虾的替代者。
你说这才多长时间。
两月吧？
差不多
那你想人工智腾的。
这个Ai的
这个他他完全
是吧？
他说完全是不挺
真的是日新的月异。
这有个很大的问题。
就是他七十二的四小时工作。
我们不只有有效时间。
就四个小时嘛？
你肯定
你就算我们时间干。
我没说这别说
对
我比这还小的
有时候
咱肯定干嘛？
知道我
这不是我这么多
是
我十六
这就是人的厉害
先内斗
你怎么跟Ai比
我们这些比
你们先内斗
小死了
对
然后
然后大家就无非在这上头。
总有一些人在试图。
把它变得更便宜
更更更便细
是吧？
但是你这个数字画的进程。
你拦不住
就是我看很多科学家。
其实预判这件事
就是Ai的发展
现在就是属于无人监管。
他正在狂奔
而且是毫无复机之理。
人类对此操作
对
你怎么没法先管
怎么管
因为现在其实特简单。
这个Ai在transform的这个框架下。
是吧？
你很多东西
你真的不知道
他是怎么涌现的
你就只需要给他
为数据就行了
你就只需要掌控这数据。
然后你就让他使劲学。
学习了之后出来新的模型。
他收缘
我们去调餐
是吧？
工程师介入一下
好
他就变聪明
你说
包括我们现在2D到3D这个。
就说这个Ai这个模型。
他现在已经与解说。
我给你一张照片
你这个空间感觉到底是什么样的。
他是猜出来
他已经是个黑盒子了。
是吧？
而且这个盒子
这个黑盒子会越来越大。
越来越黑
对
现在这个
这个下次我拿来
咱一起看一下
就是他已经说
我随便给你任何一张照片。
我就知道空间关系。
那这个模型非常厉害。
对
现在问题是模型
他还在不断的学习。
会优化
像现在
这个模型未来的一个发展。
你比如说能在游戏创作动漫。
创作这些举头
因为他
你随便给他印和一个2D的东西。
他马上就把它3D画了。
是吧？
你省得很多渲染
对
就我很容易把你
人和模型这类的事情。
很快的就能把人物数字画。
因为我有深度信息。
我就说明我已经知道你是谁了。
是的
你无非是
比如说我拍的你正面。
我不知道你背面是个啥情况。
但是我猜一下
对
比如说我看学老师这衣服。
我猜一下你背面是个啥。
我猜点都差不多
好
然后还有一个说
我如果再加一个镜头就齐活了。
嗯
等有俩镜头就够了。
对
那你原来你要把一个人解模。
你用那种特别大的。
一堆相机
你的衣币扫一点点扫。
哦
对
那你现在你只需要说。
一个镜头不够
我再添一个
完了
就所有的事情就算做完了。
那未来你比如说
我再做游戏
做建模
是吧？
那数字人在
数字世界在狂奔的这种情况下。
这种可能性都是相对比的。
他已经出漏风茫了。
是吧？
我们已经很简单
可以把任何的耳机。
我都可以变成翻译。
后面不就够了
咱这期节目录到这。
坚定了我内心的一个信念。
让我儿子学按摩
我就猜是这个
但是您想过一个问题。
你刚刚听赵老师说了。
按摩一下儿子快出来了。
就刚刚赵老师说完。
我就在找
就未来机器人
或者是就AI
他有什么理由不把人干掉。
有什么理由
没有
我找不到这个理由。
他可能觉得把你灭了。
这个资源会分配
反正是
就是至少他没有理由继续供养你。
对呀？
就是他为什么要伺候你的。
伺候你的意义在哪。
就是我为什么要服从你。
就是现在是这个问题。
是
因为现在我们还有个开关。
说我可以给你断电。
因为他现在AI的体积很大。
我需要一个很大的机房子。
但是如果某一天他自己。
人家自己能发便了。
很容易
或者他接入电网
控制了
或者他变小了
这也是更可怕的一件事情。
就他因为他现在大。
他依赖那个牛
你把他没处躲
但是如果说他变小了。
你就麻烦了
是吧？
我藏在各个手机里头。
张郎似的
你就很麻烦了
一箱柜子
三千多个小机器人出来了。
对吧？
随意比如说他大
你还好控制
你小你就很麻烦了。
嗯
现在咱就得让他废电。
哈哈哈哈
哎呦
还得买电力股票
你们人类太坏了
我跟你说
故意让他废电
所以像
但是我们就是在做小模型。
啊就是这
我就说嘛？
总有一帮
大家大家在毁灭世界的道路上。
一路苦子
对
你说你们这些科技工作是吧？
是
所以这个小模型
未来和大模型之间这种关系。
是吧？
然后
因为现在这个AI。
更多大家在聊的时候。
一聊就是那种
什么这种政治
是吧？
文明什么相关
哎
其实其实对对工程师而言。
就是没有这些
真的真的
我接触的大部分工程师。
其实他们只是
只是凭着基因里头那点神性。
但是做一点自己喜欢做的事情。
真的
但我有一个
就是不那么悲观的理由。
是最近刚找到的
就是因为我炒股
这东老师知道
在资本市场有一件事叫对冲。
嗯对
不同的公司
在做不同的模型的时候。
调出来的模型
大家都会有
思路立场
目的出现上的层次。
对
模型和模型之间
他们的损耗
未必就比人和人之间的损耗要小。
所以我现在对人类社会。
最后的希望就是这种对冲会出现。
那是均衡
反正可能就是延缓一些。
其实人类社会有一次机会对抗这个。
但是被人类自己的轮理。
现在限制不让做
谁哪次
人类要加强80年代以后。
有了基因编辑技术。
其实人类是可以自己加强自己的。
哦
自我编辑是吧？
但这条路呢？
是现在是轮理还是不允许的。
嗯
是吧？
所以这个
其实这是一个
咱偷偷干了
刘老师
我没在手里
是管婴儿算不算是一种基因编辑。
是管婴儿不算
还不太算
他算是
他没有到基因选择。
他算是基因编辑
这个滚滚车轮中的一个技术。
你比如说他编辑基因。
他一定是要去
更精细的
控制很小的
对
他们要把西红柿的基因。
给你插到你的基因。
对
我就变算了
我就
算算天天就是我
我变红
行
你六十个屁了
其实他那条路
选择染发了
轮理上很有问题
但如果真走下去
人类可能在能力上。
有一个巨大的进化。
但也可能出很多
完全可能是不少的。
真的
刘老师这么重大的责任。
舍我
骑谁在
我出一三个儿
你来搞搞这个
对
在咱国家那个战略上。
他不是
除了人工智能机器。
他不是还有生物吗？
对
生物也是好大一块。
现在做的人也很多。
生物生物
什么还一块能源
什么核区别是吧？
对
这几大块
可控核区别
还有什么困境
什么？
什么就是
量子计算
对
量子计算是一块
因为现在计算要求越来越高。
然后咱们现在的计算。
可能解决不了
计算平均
他还得选择
另外一个就是
什么心计
是吧？
心计方面的一些事。
你看
这不就是十五规划吗？
还得是咱们
对
没错
扣回来了吧？
咱最后能
最后能烙一正能量比。
可以
太过容易了
今天非常感谢张总。
跟我们算是科普了一回。
是
真的学到了好多东西。
眼镜怎么回事
也知道这东西
现在确实你要用
还有点积累
虽然老师天天跟我们鼓吹。
要用这眼镜
过程
我都说你们别买
原来是富耳机
有个人许到时候自己都品牌了。
说一说
考证一下
当你做个品牌
我就觉得靠
行
我希望给大家
如果想入这坑
提供一点信息的知识。
给你们拔点草吧？
就是
对
好
这以后有机会
张总再把他那个设备。
二维转三维的设备带过来。
咱们一块看
看这东西能创造什么有意思内容。
也希望大家在评论区里边。
给我推荐一些好的。
胶暗膜的机构
谢谢大家
好好的
我也要去
哈哈哈
谢谢
今天就聊到这
拜拜
欢迎大家关注特技手导演。